[Music]
earlier today i asked my good friend
andy to look into what would happen if
washington doesn't meet the budget
deadline and i guess he's done some
research how'd you make out andy
well to be honest i didn't have a lot of
time to put something together um
but i think i nailed it
if the president and congress don't
agree on a budget compromise then the
nation will go over the fiscal cliff
and crash into the double-dip recession
river where we will struggle in the
floundering stock market rapids but just
as we're about to go over the credit
rating devaluation falls the nation will
be sucked up by the spiraling inflation
tornado and find itself on bankruptcy
island
okay that's interesting
interesting stuff andy thank you very
much i'm not done there's more
we'll survive on bankruptcy island by
eating bad credit default nuts and
drinking our own insolvency europe
eventually we'll be rescued by the
international monetary fund lifeline but
by then all our debt will be held by
china and will be china's bits for the
next 200 years
that's great history this country really
knows how to shake its pacific northwest
it sure does andy
it sure does